[موسيقى]
طبيب وفيلسوف تلميذ بن رشد ذا عصيته في
الافاق العالم الاندلسي ابو الحجاج يوسف
بن محمد ابن طملوس والشهير باسمي ابن
طملوس
ولد في الفتره ما بين عامي 1250
والف ومئه وخمسه وستين في جزيره شقر
القريبه من بلنسيا كما كان يطلق عليها
ايام الخلافه الاندلسيه في اسبانيا
درس الفلسفه والطباء والفقه وخلف ابن رشد
طبيبا للخليفه الموحد محمد الناصر نظرا
لبرعته في هذا العلم
اهتم ابن طملوس بعلوم شتى الى جانب كونه
طبيبا فدرس الفلسفه واصبح رائدا في علم
المنطق كما اتقن النحو والف الشعر
معظم مؤلفاته ضاعت ولا يوجد سوى عملين
رئيسيين معروفين نجايا لابن طملوس هما
كتابه في المنطق وشرح العريسه
كتابه في المنطق ادرج في مخطوطه واحده
تتناول جميع اجزاء مجموعات اورجان كما في
ذلك كتاب البلاغه وكتاب الشعر وترجم هذا
الكتاب الى لغات عده اهمها الانجليزيه
والفرنسيه
تاثر بشكل كبير باعمال الغزالي والفرابي
الا ان الاثر الواضح لانتاجه الفلسفي كان
مستمدا من استاذه ابن رشد
كما يعد تعليقه على قصيده ابن سينا الطبيه
من اهم الاعمال الباقيه له التي حملت
السماء شرح العريزه ضمت في ثمان مخطوطات
معروفه تحتوي على هذا العمل
تاثرت الحضاره الغربيه كثيرا بانجازاته
وبني له تمثال
لتخليد ذكرى
[موسيقى]